the Five Nights at Freddy's movie is now
upon us and if you're a fan of the FNAF
games you probably sprinted to the
theater on opening weekend to see how
all your old friends looked on the big
screen and the evil animatronics who
occasionally haunt your dreams hopefully
you were able to spot some of the many
Easter eggs that were delicately placed
into the movie and if you didn't we've
got a bunch to tell you about so stick
around for all the Five Nights at
Freddy's Easter eggs that we found so
far when it comes to the security office
the folks making them movie didn't want
to get this one wrong it seems obvious
that a lot of care went into making it
as close to the game as possible fans of
the original game are particularly
thrilled with how close it looks to the
office in that one including some
recognizable features like the Fazbear
poster that says celebrate it also
includes things like the striped cup
fast food wrapper and more plus even the
security screens in the doors heading
out of the office seemed to match the
first game's office perfectly though
some fans were quick to know note that
the security briefing does happen in the
film a little differently instead of
getting a call like the game he views it
on a tape recording and the footage from
the security cams also changes up a bit
which some people have been calling a
little bit of a mix from the first set
of games players of the FNAF games know
that Bonnie the animatronic is the only
one who gets to go inside the janitor's
room the movie held on to this rule as
we only see Bonnie in there and of
course she made good use of her time in
the janitor's room though we want to
give out any specifics just in case you
don't want a plot spoiler here the movie
has an overt usage of drawings
throughout establishing that they're the
primary way Abby and the ghost kids
communicate so that's not necessarily an
Easter egg but one particular drawing
definitely counts early in the movie
Mike is at aby's school and you can see
there is the list with spelling words on
the chalkboard you can spot chick and
fox which are references to two of the
FNAF animatronic characters balloon
board boy is a well-known antagonist to
fans of the game so they were excited to
see him in a recurring bit in the movie
as well as in a post-credit scene during
the movie Mike has a jump scare when he
sees a statue it's of you guessed it
balloon boy obviously showing up in this
way is more of a tease than an actual
plot point that is of course until the
post credit scene in it we see the taxi
driver and there's another Easter egg
about him which we'll get to in a minute
waiting in his taxi there's a knock on
the window and the driver tries to deny
the ride he says things like not today
sorry and read the sign but his
annoyance turns immediately to fear when
he recognizes who has slid into the cap
balloon boy given the fact that balloon
boy is a big baddy beginning in the game
Five Nights at Freddy's 2 it seems
likely that this post credits Easter egg
is a nod to his potential increased
involvement in any subsequent movies
we'll see now like I mentioned before
the taxi driver himself was an Easter
egg of a cameo you might be thinking
thinking it was some famous actor who
maybe you didn't recognize but no this
Cameo was of a different sort YouTube
influencer Cory X Kenshin has long been
a Five Nights at Freddy's fan and played
a big role online in getting the game
more and more popular so much so that
when it came time to make the movie The
Producers wanted to make sure he got a
part so they cast him as the cab driver
and he did pretty well if you ask me he
got to be in a couple scenes plus that
post credit scene with balloon boy not
too shabby and he's not the only
YouTuber who got to be in the movie
there's an employees of the month sign
on the wall of the Pizzeria and it's
chalk full of YouTubers who helped
spread the word and make Five Nights at
Freddy's a phenomenon in the gaming
World up on that plaque are YouTubers
like 8bit Ryan baz razowski Fusion Z
gamer and Doo the animatronics are
trying to make Abby one of them
essentially turning her into a girl
clown this animatronic is from the games
and is called Circus baby in the game
it's also o possessed by the soul of
Elizabeth William afton's daughter the
mini Easter egg here is that Abby is not
only sometimes a nickname for Elizabeth
but also an anagram for baby so it might
spell trouble for Elizabeth in the
sequel there's a scene when a couple
characters like Aunt Jane and Max meet
in a coffee shop the name of the shop is
Sparky's coffee shop the great part of
this particular Easter egg is that it's
really for the hardcore fans because
there had been a long-standing rumor
that in the OG game there was actually a
sixth animatronic character whose name
was Sparky people even went so far as
posting screenshots of what they thought
was Sparky online but it actually turned
out not to be true so the movie gave
this whole episode a wink by naming the
coffee shop after this non-existent
Easter egg of a character oh and in the
coffee shop scene their waitress is NES
which could definitely be an Easter egg
for the nickname of Vanessa a character
from several of the games in the
restaurant there's a wall of drawings
one of which is a rainbow this is a
pretty overt nod to chica's Magic
Rainbow who's the final boss in the FNAF
World game but the chica's Easter eggs
don't stop there in the movie Mike also
works at an ice cream shop literally
called chica's Magic Rainbow throughout
the movie Mike constantly reads from a
book about the theory of Dreams this has
led some fans to wonder if it's a wink
to the idea that the whole game and the
world of the movie is one of his dreams
it certainly has a lot of elements of a
dream SL nightmare if you ask me clearly
the folks who put this movie together
didn't disappoint when it came to
linking it to the games and these Easter
eggs are just a small sample if you're
anything like me you're planning to
watch it at least 10 more times to look
for more Easter eggs and if you find any
pop them in the comment section
below